اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه الساعه
الاخباريه من العربيه والتي نخصص معظمها
لتغطيه التطورات في السودان ونبداها
بالعناوين
رغم الهدنه اشتباكات بالاسلحه الثقيله في
ام درمان وطائره الجيش تحلق في سماء
الخرطوم
السودانيه تنشر تعزيزات امنيه لتامين
الاحياء بمناطق عده في العاصمه الخرطوم
تاكيدات حكوميه العربيه هل وضع الصحي في
السودان كارثي وحركه الهجره مستمره الى
الدول المجاوره
وفي ملفات ايضا
[موسيقى]
توتر اسرائيلي فلسطيني متجدد بعد وفاه
الاسير خضر عدنان في سجن عوفر غرب رام
الله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا 18 يوما مرت على بدء
نزاع المسلح في السودان بين الجيش وقوات
الدعم السريع هدى هشام شهدتها الايام
الماضيه وسط حديث عن مفاوضات مرتقبه بين
طرفي الصراع الا ان اشتباكات عنيفه وقع
صباح اليوم في مدن سودانيه ابرزها الخرطوم
واندرمان في وقت يتساقب الازمه الصحيه
نتيجه خروج كل مستشفيات الخرطوم عن العمل
ومعاناه المنشاه من نقص حاد في المستلزمات
الطبيه لم يتوقف الامر عن عند هذا الحد
حيث بات خطر الجوع والنزوح يخيم بل يخيمان
على مستقبل السودانيين
لازم انا اشتغل
[موسيقى]
في التفاصيل المشاهدين افاد مراسو العربيه
في السودان بسماع دوري اسلحه ثقيله
للاشتباكات بين قوات الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع في منطقه المهندسين في ام
درمان حيث حلق طيران الجيش السوداني في
مدن خرطوم الثلاثه واستهدف مواقع لقوات
الدعم السريع واكد المراسل على استمرار
الاشتباكات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
في منطقه كافوري بالخرطوم بحري
وفيما شن طيران الجيش السوداني قصفا جويا
في ولايه شرق النيل بحسب مراسل ياتي ذلك
في وقت اعلنت سلطات الطيران المدني
السوداني تمديد اغلاق المجال الجوي
باستثناء طائرات الاجلاء والمساعدات
[تصفيق]
هذا واظهرت الصور تحليق للطائرات الحربيه
التابعه للجيش في سماء العاصمه الخرطوم
حيث استهدفت مواقع وتمركزات لقوات الدعم
السريعه
[تصفيق]
قال المكتب الصحفي لقوات الشرطه السودانيه
ان الشرطه بدات ارسال تعزيزات امنيه
لتامين الاسواق والمحلات التجاريه
والاحياء كما اشارت الشرطه الى قيامها
بحملات خلال الايام الثلاثه الماضيه في
عدد من مناطق جنوب الخرطوم بمشاركه
وتنسيق امني مشترك مع القوات المسلحه
[موسيقى]
انه يعني مسارات امنه جدا ما يكون فيها اي
انتهاكات لانه نحن عندنا فرص بتاع الدعم
الكبير من المؤسسات عالميه
من الخرطوم مشاهدينا ينضموا الينا مراسل
العربيه سالم الهاشمي اهلا بك سالم وجديد
الاوضاع لديك في الخرطوم وبقيه المناطق
ايضا
نعم احمد اهلا بك وبكل الساده المشاهدين
الجديد انه تتجدد الاصوات التي تسمع
بمضادات الطائرات وكذلك الطائرات تحلق هنا
في سماء الخرطوم في محيط مطار الخرطوم ليس
ببعيد من هذه المنطقه
ولعلها متقطعه وليست متواصله وهي اقل عنفا
من عصر البارحه ايضا هناك حركه شبه طبيعيه
للمواطنين في الشوارع الى حد ما نستطيع ان
نقول انها شبه طبيعيه بقضاء احتياجياتهم
خرجوا الى الشوارع الان في عديد من
المناطق في ولايه الخرطوم ليقضوا
احتياجاتهم ربما هذه المناطق هي الاكثر
خطوره وهي التي نتحدث عن حركه فيها شبه
طبيعيه اما المناطق الاخرى البعيده من
مناطق الاشتباكات والبعيده بالمناطق
الخطوره ربما تشهد حياه اقرب للطبيعيه في
خروج الناس وفتح كل المحل التجاريه وغيرها
من الامور الحياتيه الاخرى لكن هنا في
المناطق التي تشهد خطوره اعلى ربما المحل
التجا التي تفتح محدوده يضاف اليها ايضا
ندره في بعض السلع وكذلك ليس كل المحال
حتى بالنسبه للافران افران الخبز هذه
المناطق التي تركز فيها
المواجهاتها ابرز المناطق الخطيره في
العاصمه
نعم المناطق التي تشهد خطوره هي المناطق
التي بمحيط مطار الخرطوم او بالقرب من
مطار الخرطوم الشوارع الشرقيه من مطار
الخرطوم شارع الستين وشارع عبيد خاتم او
غرب مطار الخرطوم شارع المطار وحتى
العمارات هذه المناطق خرطوم اثنين هذه
المناطق تشهد خطوره عاليه وكلما اقتربت من
هذه المناطق تكون الخطوره اكثر في مدينه
بحري مثلا المناطق الاكثر خطوره هي
الشعبيه مثلا حله حمد وكذلك المزاد هذه
المناطق ايضا كلما اقتربت منها تكون
الخطوره اعلى وكل مبتعد تعتبر الخطوره اقل
في يوم درمان محيط الاذاعه والتلفزيون
المهندسين الفاتحه ربما هذه المناطق
الاكثر خطوره كلما ابتعدت من هذه المناطق
تكون الخطوره اقل هناك تكون الحركه شبه
طبيعيه في هذه المناطق الحركه تقل في
الليل تكاد تكون منعدمه او بالتاكيد هي
منعدمه تماما يضاف اليها ايضا انه بالامس
في ليله البارحه كان هناك انقطاع للتيار
الكهربائي في العديد من
المناطق الخرطوم بالتحديد مدينه الخرطوم
لكن بدا العوده التدريجيه لبعض الاحياء
وما زالت احياء تقطع عنها التيار
الكهربائي حتى الان معارك الامس من
المعركه عنيفه جدا منذ هذه الازمه بحريه
كانت من ضمن هذه المناطق ايضا هل من نتائج
معينه رشحت
اثرت على المشهد الميداني لاحد الطرفين او
كليهما
[موسيقى]
انتشار قوات الشرطه ايضا في مدن العاصمه
او في احياء العاصمه الخرطوم يعني كيف كان
اثره على الوضع الامني في البلاد
الانتشار بالنسبه لانتشار الشرطه كانت قد
تحدثت الشرطه السودانيه عن انتشار
الاحتياطي المركزي وهو احد افرع
واذرع الشرطه السودانيه ويتبع لوزاره
الداخليه لتامين الممتلكات والمنشات
وقد بدا بالفعل في مناطق متفرقه لكنه يعني
ما زال المواطنون يشكون من عمليات النهب
والسرقه ما زالت هنالك اماكن لم تصل اليها
هذه القوات هناك اماكن عديده جدا لم تصل
اليها هذه القوات بحسب شهود العيان
والمواطنين المتواجدين في تلك المناطق
ربما تحتاج الشرطه المزيد من ارسال هذه
القوات لتامين المواطنين في الاحياء
المتواجدين بها والتي يشكون فيها من النهب
والسرقات وقد تحدث المواطنون عن بؤر كثيره
جدا لعصابات تنشط ليلا ونهارا حتى هذه
العصابات تقوم بعمليات نهب وسرقه واضحه
ومعلومه وقد وثقت كاميرات المواطنين
الكثير من مثل هذه المظاهر ربما هذا ما
يجعل الدور في هذه المساله على الشرطه بان
تنتشر في تلك المناطق لمنع انتشار عمليات
النهب والسرقه لايقاف هذه العصابات من
ترويع المواطنين وحتى مداهمه منازلهم
احيانا اذا ياخرطوما مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي شكرا لك سالم على ما تفضلت به
على صعيد عمليات الاجلاء قالت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه ان قواتها الجويه قامت
باجلاء اكثر من 200 شخص من الاراضي
السودانيه بناء على قرار الرئيس فلاديمير
بوتين واشارت الى ان عمليات الاجلاء شملت
موظفي البعثه الدبلوماسيه الروسيه في
السودان
والمكاتب التمثيريه لوزاره الدفاع الروسيه
وعائلاتهم من مواطني روسيا وبلدان رابطه
الدول المستقله وعدد من الدول الاجنبيه
الصديقه
افاد المتحدث باسم الخارجي الامريكيه
من السودان عبر ثلاث قوافل في وقت كان
البيت الابيض قد اعلن نشر طائرات لمراقبه
عمليه الاجلاء
ليس هناك اي عدد محدد نصح عنه لاعداد
المواطنين الامريكيين الذين غادروا
السودان المواطنون الامريكيون هم من
يتخذون القرار بشان المغادره بحسب
اولوياتهم تواصلنا خلال هذه الازمه مع
اكثر من 5000 مواطن امريكي مقيم في
السودان واجلينا الفا مواطن منهم عبر ثلاث
قوافل
كما ثملت الخارجيه الامريكيه جهود
السعوديه في استقبال المواطنين الامريكيين
وايضا للمساعده في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان عموما
اود القول ان السعوديه لعبت دورا مهما ليس
فقط في استقبال مواطنينا لكن في دعم
الرباعيه وكانت حلقه وصل في الدفع بتمديد
هدنه الاثنتين وسبعين ساعه
على مهلك على مهلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
العربيه الثانيه خلاص
الله يحييك
في مصر تستمر عمليات استقبال السودانيين
من الاشتباكات في بلادهم اغلب القادم
ياتون من خلال منفذ قسطل البري ومن بعده
يصلون لمدينه ابو سمبل عن طريق عبارات نهر
النيل احمد عثمان والتفاصيل في التقرير
التالي
نحن الان امام المرسى النيلي لمدينه ابو
سمبل في انتظار العبارات النيليه القادمه
والتي يستقلها السودانيون القادمون عبر
منفذ قسطل البري في اصعب من كيد كونك تخلي
دارك
بدايه الحرب في المنازل انعطاع التيار
الكهربائي الميه ما فيش ما فيش ولا حاجه
وعلى الرغم من استمرار لتدفق القادمين من
السودان الى مصر باعداد كبيره الا ان هناك
من يفضل استقلال نفس الحافلات للعوده الى
السودان حاليا السودان في ازمه
واهالي الخرطوم كلهم جايين الى مصر هذا
المكان يعد مكانا للراحه للقادمين
المرهقين من السودان قبل ان يستانفوا
رحلاتهم مره اخرى سواء الى اسوان او الى
القاهره وجدت تعامل طيب جدا حقيقه من
اخواننا المصريين كانهم اخواتنا انا ومع
غروب الشمس تتوقف حركه العبارات النيليه
لينتظر الجميع سطوع شمس يوم جديد لكل من
يريد ان يذهب او ياتي الى الاراضي المصريه
من السودان احمد عثمان لقنتي العربيه
والحدث من مدينه ابو سمبل محافظه اسوان
من اسوان مشاهدينا جنوب مصر ينضم الينا
المحلل السياسي السوداني عمار عوض معنا في
هذه التغطيه وعطفا على تواجدك في اسوان
وعلى الاغلب عائشه اوضاع السودانيين
الراغبين في مغادره البلاد او العوده
اليها في المعابر هناك ما الذي يمكن ان
تخبرنا به عن مشاهداتك
ما يمكن ان يقوله المرء ان هذه الازمه رغم
انها ازمه انسانيه كبيره ازمه حرب لكن هي
اعاده
كثير من جسور الثقه ما بين الشعب السوداني
والشعب
المصريين الذين وجدناهم في منذ
مدخل في منطقه غسطل حتى المحافظه حتى في
اسوان تحس كانك في بيتك يقدمون لك كل ما
هو ممكن حتى اذا كان تحديد السيارات حتى
اذا كان تحديد اماكن الاقامه
الوجبات الساخنه الوجبات البارده التحديد
اسعار حتى لا يكون هنالك استغلال من
اصحاب الباصات لازمه السودانيين
تسهيل في اجراءات تاشيرات الدخول حتى
عندما تم تسليمنا امس ما يتعلق بشرائح
الاتصالات علمنا مندوبي شركه اتصالات بان
الاتصالات ستكون مجانيه ما بين السودان
ومصر الى حين انجلاء هذه الازمه هذا في
الجانب المصري لكن هنالك في الجانب
السوداني هنالك ازمه اساسيه عزيزي تتحدث
تتحدث في ضعف البنيه التحتيه في مدينه
حلفا ومن هنا انا احيي كل مواطني مدينه
حلفا الذين فتحوا بيوتهم فتحوا منازلهم
فتحوا المدارس كل منزل يكتفي اصحاب المنزل
بثلاثه اسره او اربعه سر في اصحاب المنزل
وبقيه الاسر الموجوده
والمراتب وغيرها الموجوده يتم تحويلها
مباشره الى المدارس لكن هنالك استغلال من
اصحاب البساطه السفريه في مضاعفه اسعار
التذاكر السفر هنالك مشكله في ان المدينه
مصممه لاستيعاب حوالي 10,000 والموجودين
في مدينه حلفا حوالي 100 الف الوضع اصعب
من الجهه الاخرى في معبر اركين لكن من
المشاهدات من مدينه حلفا حتى ام درمان
هنالك وجود كامل
للجيش السوداني تجد بعض نقاط التفتيش ليس
هنالك اي وجود لقوات الدعم السريع ليس
هنالك اي خطوره على حياه المواطنين من
ناحيه الاطلاق نار او غيره
المواطنين ايضا في مدينه دنغولا يقدمون كل
ما هو ممكن للبساطه القادمه من تسكين
للسكان وتقديم الوجبات المشاكل تتحدث
في ضعف شبكه الانترنت مما يعيق العمليات
التحويلات البنكيه للاسر
علمنا ان خدمتهم عاد مجددا ذلك سيرفع كثير
من الرهط لان المواطنين لم يخرجوا
باموالهم خرجوا فقط
البنكيه اشرت اليها سيدي عمار ومنع
المقاطع لكن هل تعتقد ان النزوح والهجره
سيكونان هما الخيار
الاول السوداني في المرحله المقبله
المقبله هل بات الامل مفقودا في انجلاء
هذه الازمه في مراحيلها الاولى دون الوصول
الى مرحله الانهيار الشامل في البلاد
لا لا لا لا اعتقد ان السودان مقبل على
مرحله انهيار هذا سؤال جيد مثلما كان
يتحدث غاده الجيش بانهم في الايام الاولى
كانوا يمتصون الصدمه المتعلقه
بالضربات ثم من بعد ذلك بداوا في مرحله
ثانيه اعتقد دون ترتيب مسبق السودانيين في
في المرحله الاولى كانت هنالك ما يتعلق
بالصدمه الاسر لم تكن متعوده على اطلاق
النار داخل الخرطوم ليسوا متعودين على صوت
الطائرات ليسوا متعودين على صوت مضادات
الطائرات كان هنالك خوف بعد خروج المساجين
او معتادين الاجرام من السجون الذين قاموا
قامت باطلاقهم قوات الدعم السريع كل هذه
الخيانه كل هذه الوقائع جعلت المواطنين
يقرون من الخرطوم الى خارج السودان او الى
مدن امنه داخل السودان لكن الان عندما
اتحدث مع اسرتي المنتشره في مناطق كثيره
في السودان اذا كان في مدينه بورسودان
التي عادت فيها الحياه الى طبيعتها بل حتى
انها اصبحت
مرجحه ان تكون هي عاصمه بديله في دنقله في
الابيض في غير عاده الحياه لطبيعتها بدا
الناس يشعرون يداولون اعمالهم بالتالي ذلك
سيقلل من النزوح ذلك يقودني الى ما تفضل
به الدكتور عبد الله حمدوك امس في
الاجتماع الذي عقد في نيروبي شارك فيه
الرئيس الكيني شارك فيه الاتحاد الافريقي
هم تحدثوا عن ما يتعلق بحديثنا هم تحدثوا
عن
ممرات امنه لعبور المساعدات الانسانيه
تحدث عن ان يكون هنالك وخدي شامل لاطلاق
النار او اطلاق محادثات حول تثبيت وخفي
اطلاق النار ما يهمني في هذا الامر هو
الحديث عن ممرات امنه اعتقد ان السودانيين
ابتدعوا
ذاكرتهم الجمعيه ممراتهم الامنه اصبح
هنالك ثلاثه ممرات الممر الاول هو الذي
يمر من الخرطوم الى دندن الى حلفا الى
ارجيم المره الثاني الذي يمر من الخرطوم
الى عقبره الى بورسودان المره الثالثه
الذي يمر من الخرطوم الى كوستي الى الرانك
ثم الى جنوب السودان المره الاخير هو الذي
فيه اشكاليه وهو الذي يتعلق بالعابرين من
دارفور الى ولايات
المتاخمه في دوله تشاد نسبه للازمه التي
حصلت في الجنينه ذلك يهودني لماذا اقول
ذلك ان السودانيين لم نعد نحن نحتاج لان
يكون هناك
وجود دولي لتحديد ممرات امنه الممرات
الامنه حددت بالاخلاق السودانيه حددت
بالكره الذي يتميز به السودانيين ولكن ان
ياتي
مجموعات من دول العالم
[موسيقى]
الوجود قوات الدعم السريع يمكن ان يشكل
عائقا
لكن نحن عندما نتحدث عن تثبيت هدنه
كسودانيين او على غله تقدير كمركز سوداني
يونايت جروب الذي نحن الان نعمل عبره فيما
يتعلق التوصيل التي قدمناها لاصدقائنا اذا
كان في الاجتماع الذي كان في كينيا او
غيره انه يجب عندما نتحدث عن
الممرات امنه او نتحدث عن
وقفي لاطلاق النار يمكن ان يتم تحديد
العلامات التي توضع على هذه السيارات وهي
علامات الصليب الاحمر علامات
الامم المتحده خطوره دخول المراقبين الى
السودان هو انه يثبت الوضع الموجود على ما
هو عليه يعقد الازمه انا شخصيا عملتها
فيما يتعلق الازمه السوريه كصحفيا غطيت
هذه الازمه هي كانت بدايتها على هذه
الشاكله كان هنالك اللجنه التي يقوده
الفريق الدابس ثم بدا الناس يتحدثوا عن
وقف اطلاق مارس ثم بداوا يتحدثوا عن نشر
للمراقبين الدوليين الان التقارير
الاخباريه تتحدث على ان الدول الكبرى التي
بدات تتكلم على السودان عن طريق ليبيا
يمكنك ان تطالع التقرير الذي اعده صديقنا
في صحيفه الجارديان كيف ان هنالك
دخول من ليبيا ما نريده من المجتمع الدولي
ليس هو الاصطفاف لممر انساني في بورسودان
ما نريده هو يتم اغلاق الحدود مع ليبيا
لمنع وحل الازمه ايضا مع الوقوف في الحياد
نعم اعتذر منك نعم هذا ما سمح به الوقت
شكرا لك من اسوان كنت معنا في جنوب مصر
المحلل السياسي السوداني عمرها
مشاهدينا على صعيد الجهود دبلوماسيه
العربيه وفي كلمتها امام المندوبين
الدائمين في الجامعه العربيه الذين عقدوا
اجتماعا في القاهره لبحث الاوضاع في
السودان جدد فهد الخمع الانائب المندوب
الدائم للسعوديه لدى الجامعه العربيه دعوه
بلاده لايقاف المواجهات في السودان للحفاظ
على حياه المدنيين
ان المملكه العربيه السعوديه
تجدد دعوتها لسرعه وقف العمليات العسكريه
والتحلي باقصى درجات ضبط النفس وتجنب
التصعيد وتقريب مصلحه الشعب السوداني
للحفاظ على مكتسباته ومقدراته والعوده الى
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي يهدف الى الوصول
الى اعلان سياسي يحقق الامن والاستقرار
للسودان وشعبه الشقيق
في سياق اكد محمد مصطفى عرفي مندوبه مصر
الدائم لدى الجامعه العربيه على ضروره وقف
اطلاق النار فورا في السودان
اننا نؤكد من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس على
ضروره الوقف الفوري غير المشروط للعنف
واتاحه الفرصه كامله لانجاح جهود التسويه
وجعلها تؤتي ثمارها في القريب العاجل
ونحذر من هنا باسم رئاسه المجلس من ان
المساس في المدنيين بالسودان واستهداف
منشاتهم لا سيما الطبيه منها هو امر خطير
للغايه ويمثل انتهاكا واضحا وسافرا
للقانون الدولي والقانون الدولي الانساني
من جانبه اكد امجد العضاه الى مندوب
الاردن لدى الجامعه العربيه ان كافه
الاطراف في السودان عليها التحلي
بالمسؤوليه وشددا على ضروره ايجاد حل
داخلي سوداني يعكس تطلعات السودانيين
بعيدا عن اي تدخلات خارجيه
ونؤكد ضروره تحلي كافه الاطراف بروح
المسؤوليه الوطنيه واعلاء المصالح العليا
للسوداني وشعبه الشقيق فوق اي اعتبار اخر
حقنا لدماء السودانيين وتفاديا لقتال بين
ابناء الشعب الواحد لن يكون المنتصر فيها
الا خاسرا فالقاتل والمقتول اخوه والثمن
المدفوع امن واستقرار ومنعت السودان
واستقلاله ووحدته ووحدته ودماء ابنائه
ونؤكد ان اي حل للازمه الراهنه لابد ان
يكون حلا داخليا سودانيا يعكس اراده
وتطلعات الشعب السوداني الشقيق بعيدا عن
اي تدخلات خارجيه
هكذا رئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي ان المنطقه
كلها يمكنها يمكن ان تتاثر بالصراع في
السودان وشهدت العاصمه المصريه القاهره
لقاء جمع وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري
بسفير دفع الله الحاج علي المبعوث الخاص
لرئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد الفتاح
برهان وجرى خلال اللقاء بحث الازمه
السودانيه والصراع المستمر منذ 18 يوما
من القاهره
العربيه اهلا بك تامر وما الذي رشحني
معلومات حول هذا اللقاء الذي جمع وزير
الخارجيه البصري
صباح الخير يا احمد اللقاء انتهى يبدو منذ
دقائق معدوده يعني كنا حضرنا دخول السيد
دفع الله الحاج الى الخارجيه المصريه
واستقبال الوزير سامح شكري الاول منذ
دقائق او دقيقه واحده تقريبا وانت في معرض
تقديمك لهذه الفقره صدر بيان عن الخارجيه
ساقراه عليك على الهواء لان لانه وصلني
فورا ان وزير المبعوث السوداني نقل الى
وزير الخارجيه رساله شفهيه من رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه الى فخامه الرئيس عبد
الفتاح السيسي يعني هذا طبعا كنا نتوقع ان
تكون مثل هذا الامر خاصه ان عاده ما تقرا
الاتصالات بين مجلس السياده السوداني
والرئاسه مباشره ولكن في وجود زياره رئيس
الوزراء الياباني الان دخلت الدبلوماسيه
المصريه على سبيل التنسيق وخاصه ان هناك
ايضا
سماعات تدور في جامعه الدول العربيه على
مستوى المندوبين اعود الى البيان مره اخرى
يتحدث عن ان السيد دافعال الحاج قدم الشكر
على استقبالها للسودانيين الفارين من
الاحداث وتوفير الرعايه وخلافه ايضا
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه قال ان الوزير شكري
اكد على موقف مصر من
القضيه في السودان
وانه شان داخلي يجب ان تنقل جميع الاطراف
الاقليميه والدوليه عن التدخل فيه كما
يقول
البيان هنا كذلك ان هناك ايضا اهميه
الالتزام الجميع الاطراف بتثبيت الهدنه
وعدم خرقها لاتاحه الفرصه لعمليات الاغاثه
الانسانيه
[موسيقى]
تحدث البيان ايضا عن الرساله للمجتمع
الدولي الداعيه الى ضروره وقف الاغتسال
الدائر
حمايه لمقدرات الشعب السوداني اعتقد يعني
اهم النقاط التي جاءت في البيان والتي
يظهر منها اجليا انها كانت هناك يعني نوع
من المطالب لمصر تم توجيهه
للرئيس عبد الفتاح السيسي من خلال
الخارجيه المصريه السيد دفع الله الحاج
سيتوجه بعد قليل الى مقر جامعه الدول
العربيه حيث تستمر
اللقاءات الخاصه بالمندوبين الدائمين التي
بدات بالامس وكانت قد بدات بدايه غير
معتاده بالنسبه لنا كصحفيين واعلاميين وهي
بمنع تواجدنا على الاطلاق سواء كمراسلين
للصحف او مراسلين للقنوات التلفزيونيه حتى
يعني ان هذا يعني امر غير معتاد على الاقل
بالنسبه لاجتماعات المندوبين الدائمين
التي عاده ما تكون تحضيريه مثلا
الاجتماعات وزراء الخارجيه ولكن وزراء
الخارجيه تقريبا غالبيتهم كانوا موجودين
في عمان بالامس من اجل الشان السوري
فبالتالي كان امرا مستغربا لهذه الناحيه
على الجانب الاخر دفع الله الحاج عندما
يتوجه الى الجامعه العربيه هو من المرجح
بطبيعه الحال انه سيلتقل امين العام
والامين العام المساعد ولكن هل يتحدث ايضا
الى اجتماع المندوبين الدائمين ام لا هذا
لم يتضح حتى هذه اللحظه هناك طلبات على
المستوى الدبلوماسي للتنسيق العربي
وللتقديم الدعم لمجلس السياده السوداني في
هذا الامر وان كان معظم الدول العربيه قد
اعلنت موقفها بوضوح في هذا الشان والدافع
الى ان يكون الحوار سلميا وان يكون هناك
اولا وقف لاطلاق النار وتثبيت هذه الهدنه
حتى تتمكن الامور من الاستقرار من اجل ان
يكون هناك عمليه دبلوماسيه واضحه المعالم
لا ان تكون مشوبه بعمليات الاقتتال التي
تحدث كل فتره وانا وانت شاهدنا يا احمد
على مدار الايام الماضيه وكذلك جميع
الساده المشاهدين خروقات تمت للهدنه من
الجانبين وتبادل الاتهامات في هذا الامر
عموما يعني هذا هو المجمل الحادث هنا في
القاهره على هذا الصعيد شكرا جزيلا لك على
كل هذه المعلومات والتفاصيل وسنكون معك في
متابعه دائم العيد تطورات جديده في هذا
الملف شكرا من القاهره مراسل العربيه تامر
نصرت
اقترح رئيس الوزراء السوداني السابق عبد
الله حمدوك اجراء حوار عاجل بين الجيش
والدعم السريع لتوفير الاساسي لوقف دائم
لاطلاق النار بالاضافه الى وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار يخضع للمراقبه والاتفاق على
انشاء ممرات انسانيه دائمه واقترح حمدوك
ايضا اشراك المدنيين السودانيين في
مفاوضات شامله واستئناف العمليه السياسيه
مؤكدا على ان استمرار الحرب في السودان
وانتشارها في رقعه اوسع قد يضر العالم
باسره
في حديث خاص مع العربيه قال المبعثره
الاموي الى السودان ان العمل جاري لوضع
التفاصيل
لمفاوضات السودان مع الامريكيين
والسعوديين ورجح ان تجرى مفاوضه الحل في
السعوديه
اداره
الاعمال
الفنيه هلا مع الامريكان والسعوديين فبطئت
بالارجا
سيتم الارجح طبعا يعني الجانبين لازم ان
يوافق على على هذا المكان
وانا ما بحكي هلا انت افوت سياسي انا بحكي
عن محادثات حول حلول فنيه الى ما
لانشاء وتاسيس اليه
لوقفه لك نار دائم وثابت مع اليه مراقبه
والتحكم على وقفه لكن
وفي متابعه الاوضاع الطبيه قال سكرتيره
نقابه الاطباء السودانيه عطيه عبد الله
هنا الوضع الصحي كارثي هوصفا ما يحدث في
القطاع الطبي بالجريمه الانسانيه واضاف ان
كل المستشفيات العامه في الخرطوم توقفت عن
العمل حيث دعا اطراف الصراع لوقف قتال
فورا واكد ان الوضع صحيا كارثي في الجنينه
بدارفور محذر من الوضع نفسه في باقي
الولايات اذا ما استمرت المواجهات وقال ان
مستشفيات خرجت من الخدمه بسبب عدم توفر
الوقود
كل هذه العوامل مجتمعه وهو ما ظللنا ان
نحذر منه منذ اليوم الاول ستؤدي الى الى
نتيجه لا نتمناها ابدا وهي انهيار النظام
الصحيه نحن نتخوف ان يحدث مع يعني يحصل ما
حدث الجنينه في عدد من المدن وهو ما نتخوف
عنه لذلك نحن مطالبه لطرفي الصراع الان هي
ايقاف هذه الحرب داخل الولايات الخرطوم
هنالك مستشفيات توقفت تماما لانه ما فيها
معينات طبيه
ازمه اخرى مشاهدينا تنتظر السودانيين
النزوح هربا من الاقتتال حيث اكد المتحدث
باسم الامين العام المتحده ستيفانك ان
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين تخطط الاستخبار اكثر من 800 الف
شخص قد يفيرون من القتال في السودان الى
الدول المجاوره
يدعم صندوق الامم المتحده للسكان الشركاء
على الارض بالرعايه الصحيه المنقذه للحياه
ومعدات الولاده الامنه تخطط المفوضيه
الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين
بالتشاور مع الحكومات والشركاء لاستقبال
اكثر من 800 الف شخص قد يفرون من القتال
في السودان الى الدول السبع المجاوره تؤكد
احدث الارقام من فرقنا على الارض ان 73
الف شخص قد وصلوا الى البلدان المجاوره
مما في ذلك اللاجئون السودانيون ولا سيما
من جنوب السودان
مشاهدينا من اقليم دار فوري ينضم الينا
الصحفي صالح ابو علامه اهلا بك صالح معنا
في هذه النشره وبدايه ما الذي يمكن ان
تخبرنا به عن حقيقه الاوضاع الامنيه
والانسانيه في اقليم دارفور
الزميل احمد الهادي قبل ان نسقط المكان
الذي نحن فيه الان
دعنا نتحدث عن ما يجري في غرب دارفور
مدينه الجنينه ليله البارحه تم توقيع على
وثيقه لوقف العدائيه بين المجموعات
السكانيه المتحاربه في غرب دارفور
ونصت الوثيقه على وقف العدائيات بين
الطرفين عدم حمل السلاح بعدم ارتداء
الازياء العسكريه وعدم اطلاق العيره
الناريه مع فتح الحدود بين تشاد وبين غربي
دارفور او فتح الطرقات بين التاد وبين
غربي اذا ارفقت كما ورد على الوثيقه وايضا
منع التجمعات داخل الاسواق وداخل الاحياء
السكنيه بغربي دارفور مع فتح الطرق ايضا
داخل الاحياء وداخل
الاسواق وداخل الطرقات
بغربي دارفوره هنالك ردود افعال رصدناها
هنالك مرحبين بهذه الوثيقه وهنالك بعض
الذين يرون بان هذه الوثيقه يجب ان تحوي
ايضا محاسبه من ارتكبوا الجرم في هذه
الاحداث التي راح ضحيتها نفر كبير من غرب
دارفور وعدد كبير من الجرحى هنالك هدوء في
الجنينه حتى الان
الوثيقه على ارض الواقع بتفريغ التجمعات
ومنع اطلاق الاعير الناريه ومنع مظاهر
التفلت النهب وغيرها
ومنع اتلاف المؤسسات العامه
للحرائق يعني هل يعود للاشتباكات بين
القبائل واشتراكات القبليه ام الاشتباكات
بين الجيش والدعم السريع
نعم نحن هنا في جنوب دارفور اليوم هذه
المنطقه هي منطقه تقع في مرمى النيران بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نحن هنا في سوق
التوابل سوق التوابل تعرض لحريق كبير جراء
الاحداث بين الدعم السريع والجيش الايام
الماضيه تم حرق هذا السوق تماما جراء
القذائف التي سقطت على السوق كما انه
بجوار هذا السوق ايضا تم حرق سوق الذره
تماما ايضا دمار كبير في هذا المكان دمار
كبير شمل جميع المحلات التجاريه الواقعه
في هذه البقعه يحدثنا اكثر عن هذا السوق
عما ادم مرحب بيك حسين احمد اسماعيل رئيس
هو التوابل اي سوق الشطف
يعني ما الذي حدث في سوق التواب والله زين
كما ترى يعني احنا اول حاجه بلادي وان
جارت علي
ظنوا عليه كراما احنا والله هذه الحرب
اللعينه اللي فرضت على الناس نسال الله ان
حمد وتنطفئ نارها وبلادنا عزيزه علينا انه
احنا من ضحايا هذا الحرب هذا السوق مؤسس
من 47 هي بورصه السودان الغربيه افريقيا
الوسطى اشجاد نيجيريا الكاميرون ليبيا
والعاصمه كلها كل المحاصيل التجار بتعامل
من هنا حصل انه وجع دانتين في السوق وحصل
انفجار وبالتالي ما قدروا يسيطروا عليه
الاسوا من كده احنا جيران مع المطافي انا
بعد ثلاثه ساعات انا وصلت السوق ده
المطافي
حجم الخسائر حجم الخسائر حتى لحد امس امس
احنا حصرنا لسبعين في الميه ستميه
مليار و564 880 ده 70% والحصر ماشي الحصر
ماشي شو الحاجات اللي تم
توابل شطه
ويكا صلصه بن بهارات المختلفه المتينه من
اسيا ومن تركيا ومن الجهات الثانيه البن
وكل هذه المحاصيل النقديه عاليه حبهان
فتجاره عاليه الناس بمعاملاتهم
من الكاميرون يا جماعه بتعامل مع الناس
عبر الخرطوم مباشره مع الصين تجد كل
المواد اتحرقت واحنا
نعم نعم كل السودان كله
السودان كله بياخذ منه نعم يديك العافيه
شنو الحاجه اللي انت بس شغالين عليها احنا
والله طبعا شغالين في الحصر زي ما ذكرت
احنا اليوم حصرنا لحد امس لحد اربعه قفلنا
الحصر كان 653 مليار
و56480 وده هذا يعادل 70% فقط وحصل
فما فوق
اخونا محمد الحسن ابو شوشه قيم المباني دي
برضو هتضاف للتكلفه برضو رجل وحبيبي
للجيش ودعم السريع
وقف العدائيه بين الجيش
تكون على قلب رجل واحد متنفس حمايه لارواح
المواطنين والممتلكات جزاك الله جزاكم
الله خير يعطيكم العافيه هذا هو السوق
التوابل كما تابعنا وكما سمعنا من لجنه
سوق التوابل اذا اثار
حرق واثار كبيره ايضا لتدمير التجاريه
عامه هنا في التوابل بجنوب دارفور
كنت معنا الصحفي صالح ابو علامه شكرا
الكريم تحياتي
مشاهدينا يعيشون الف لاجئ سوداني يعانون
مراره اللجوء في تشاد اغلبيتهم من النساء
والاطفال منهم من يعاني من امراض تنفسيه
خطيره غير ان يونيوسف حذرت من البقاء في
قريه
خوفا من موسم الامطار المقبل
نهايتها عصيه طريق اللجوء يطول وصلنا
وحيدات الى تشاد لاجئه سودانيه دون مواعيد
بعضهن تمكنا من الدفع فقلى عليهن عبء
الطريق نساء واطفال هربوا من حرب اشتعلت
فجاه خيار اللجوء لا مفر منه ضمن حرب
بحصيله كبيره للقتله
البيوت
استقروا هنا على الحدود الارشاديه
السودانيه كبرات السن لم تعد لهن القدره
على المضي بينما الاطفال اغلبهم يعانون من
امراض تنفسيه وسوء تغذيه
20,000 لاجئ سوداني استقروا في قريه كفرون
تشاديه قريه تفتقر لاساسيات الحياه وضروره
تغيير المكان باتت حتميه
اذا فشلنا في التحرك الان سيفوت الاوان
سياتي موسم الامطار قريبا واذا لم نقدم
مساعده للناس سيتم اغلاق الطريق وسيظل
اللاجئون عالقين هنا
يبدو ان البقاء هنا طويل مخيم اللجوء باتت
تتشكل ملامحهم عشرات الاسقف واعمده علها
تشد بيت لاجئ الى حين عوده غيداء السالم
العربيه
كانت الكاميرا العربيه جوله مع المواطنين
السودانيين في بعض احياء الخرطوم الوقوف
على مدى تاثير واقع الاشتباكات والمعارك
على حياتهم نشاهد
حاليا
عندي خمسه اطفال
ومن يوم الاحداث دي حصلت انا
كويس انا
يخلوها
ويرجعوا لصوت العقل والسودان كبير بيشيل
الناس كلها
ودار اتكلم على انه المفروض ينزل لنا
الشرطه نحن المواطنين
احتمال بعد شويه يجونا داخلين في البيوت
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم والله الواحد كان
مواطن سوداني يعني بيتالم
قلم شديد جدا جدا الوضع الحاطي في البلد
وانا يعني ما اقدر اقول يعني اقوم اقول
انه البلد فيها
الخدمات في البنزين وفي الوقود وكذا تردي
عام تردي يا عم
اخواننا يعني قدمت قدمت شهداء وقدمت وقدمت
تقدم من زمان وهسه
محمد مجدي مكي مسرحيه يا اخوان هزيله
وبايخه جدا جدا من الجيزان ومن المتسلمين
اخونا
كانت حكومه سريه وكانت ماسه انقلب على
انقلب برهان صح
يا اخوان الوضع بالطريقه دي يا اخواننا
انا ضد الحرب
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات